[Musique]
les Français en sont à leur premier
déplacement de 2023 il est encore tôt
pour anticiper la direction que prendra
cette nouvelle année mais avec une
réforme des retraites que le
gouvernement a comptabtiqué d'ici l'été
contestation et mobilisation pourrait
marquer les prochains mois avertissent
certains syndicats le gouvernement veut
mettre une réforme des retraites que
nous on estime injuste et inéquitable et
donc ça risque d'attiser encore plus les
braises en France le système fonctionne
par répartition c'est à dire que les
Français qui travaillent en ce moment
cotisent pour payer la retraite de ceux
qui ne sont plus sur le marché de
l'emploi le gouvernement affirme que ce
système est menacé notamment en raison
du vieillissement de la population selon
le CDE en 1950 pour un retraité Français
on comptait environ 5 personnes
potentiellement actives sur le marché du
travail en 2020 cette proportion est
passée environ 1 pour 3 l'organisation
internationale prévoit qu'en 2050 pour
un retraité il y aura moins de deux
Français en âge de travailler
le ratio entre les retraités et les
actifs est absolument déterminant pour
l'équilibre des contes de retraite ce
qui caractérise le système français
c'est l'ampleur de notre système de
retraite 14 % du produit intérieur brut
de ses colossal
pour financer ce système différente
propositions ont été évoquées par des
politiciens des experts et des syndicats
par exemple augmenter les cotisations
notamment la part des employeurs autre
option diminuer les prestations versées
au retraités ces deux idées n'ont pas
été retenues par le gouvernement l'autre
piste est donc de faire travailler les
Français plus longtemps donc relever le
seuil de l'âge de départ à la retraite
comme je m'y suis engagé devant vous
cette année sera en effet celle d'une
réforme des retraites qui vise à assurer
l'équilibre de notre système pour les
années et décennies à venir
il nous faut travailler davantage au
cours des 10 prochaines années certains
pays européens comme l'Allemagne et la
Belgique vont faire passer l'âge de la
retraite qui est en ce moment fixé à 65
ans à 67 ans en Italie ce seuil est déjà
fixé à 67 ans ici en France où l'âge de
départ légal à la retraite et 62 ans le
gouvernement entend progressivement le
faire passer à 64 voire 65 ans des
exceptions seraimées nues pour les
personnes handicapées et pour les
Français qui ont connu une langue
carrière qui ont donc commencé à
travailler avant l'âge de 20 ans cela
pourrait également s'appliquer aux
travailleurs qui pratiquent des métiers
difficiles qui sont par exemple exposés
au bruit ou à des températures extrêmes
ou encore qui sont appelés à travailler
la nuit ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un gouvernement s'aventure sur
l'épineux chemin des réformes de
retraite en 2010 sous Nicolas Sarkozy
l'Assemblée nationale avait adopté une
législation faisant passer l'âge légal
de la retraite de 60 à 62 ans un
changement qui avait été accueilli par
plusieurs manifestations
[Applaudissements]
en 2019 des manifestants ont également
marché dans les rues pour s'opposer à
une première tentative de réforme des
retraites par Emmanuel Macron cette
proposition qui aurait revu la base même
du système français a finalement été
abandonné en 2020 pendant la pandémie
en France il y a des métiers qui ont le
plus de facilité à faire grève et
incontester on va tout faire pour que le
pays se mette de bataille comme cette
réforme qu'on juge nous injuste une
équitable la France un pays à la
conflictualité très élevée très très
élevée mais difficilement prévisible
donc il est tout à fait possible que la
France vive un conflit social de très
grande ampleur comme il est tout à fait
possible que cette réforme des retraites
finalement passe sans difficulté majeure
[Musique]
les grands syndicats s'opposent tous à
l'augmentation de l'âge du départ à la
retraite de récent sondage montre aussi
qu'une majorité de Français est
défavorable à cette réforme malgré les
risques de manifestations et de grève le
gouvernement semble cette fois-ci
déterminé à agir cette année le dossier
des retraites devrait donc marquer
l'actualité politique et sociale